did you know anything at all about mr
lee before he met him
i knew he was the drummer for mommy crew
did you find him attractive i like to
smile
first i'm going to start with lily and
sebastian sort of asking you the same
thing because you both sort of shocked
all of us when we saw those first look
photos so i'm actually going to ask each
of you
when your co-star shocked you on how
much they looked like their real
counterpart in smash and i'll start with
you because
i'm sorry the internet thought that was
pamela anderson with those photos i
thought it was
myself
um
listen without without obviously you've
seen the show you know i don't want to
give too much away here but but there's
uh there's a moment in and one of my
favorite moments of the entire show it
happens in episode three
and it's a moment um
where lily has the scene that she's you
know talking to a publicist but
i saw that scene and to me i felt
again it was like the perfect
combination of
everything you'd want right like
for me as a viewer i think like you know
the performance the writing what it's
saying
what what that scene was saying about
pamela the way
lily performed it which was
you know entirely in my opinion
as close as it could possibly get to her
you know and and it's just this
beautiful moment that you really
understand you're you're hearing about
where where she's
where she's at in her mind what she's
seeking what she wants for herself and i
just think it's such a beautiful moment
and you deserve everything for it
i know exactly what you're talking about
and you're 100
correct yeah lily i mean i'm sure you
can say the same thing because
it's strange i've seen a lot of tommy
lee and i've seen a lot of sebastian and
other things but they were
indistinguishable moments yeah i mean
that's bad no but you do he and he
inhabits every like every
fiber of him it's so like in the moment
it's like so real so to see
him have that quality as an actor and
then like be completely be tommy is
every like
the energies of the it was just really
um
it made me way better just because i
could you know be with sebastian being
they told me
i love it and it's such a weird thing
for me because i'm like wait a minute
that's like the winter soldier and the
girl from downton abbey like this is
weird to see you guys just completely
transform but what's great is i think
you're bringing aside to these people
that people think they know that maybe
they don't know the intimacy of their
relationship and what they went through
so i'm just curious starting with you
lily what do you hope people take from
pam and tommy's relationship having seen
the show
well i hope that they are very surprised
potentially or at least that they learn
more about
what went on and how that has greatly
impacted us you know in ways that we
couldn't even imagine and and sort of
look at you know i think this show does
ask us some difficult questions and to
look at our own
behavior and culpability and and um
so
yeah i i am
that was what i felt reading the scripts
i really felt this great sense of oh
wow
this is sort of not what i'd expected
and so
i hope that the viewers have a similar
experience
yeah and then sebastian yeah real quick
what about you well here's here's what's
scary right like there's a lot of people
who had texted me
um
when they when they read that i was
going to be part of it and and they were
like oh yeah they they but they sold
that tape right they and it's like no
that's not what happened
you know and and so again just just
knowing that a lot of people actually
didn't really know the true story of
you know how it even was taken from them
the the actual invasion of privacy if
you
you know going to sleep at night and
you know as things are happening it's
just uh unfannable to sort of think
about but but again um i think just just
telling the story for for from the facts
point of view is important enough um
yeah because it was like coinciding with
the birth of the internet it's like
mind-blowing you'd be reading it and
you're like what is such an
unprecedented situation and you're
forgetting that she's becoming a mom
and she's pregnant and she's trying to
build a family and she's trying to deal
with
what that
is you know and and you're dealing with
that's what you're waking up and you're
looking at you know it's just
yeah i don't i don't feel like we've
really thought about that very much yeah
everyone looks beautiful and perfect is
that how you feel like you have to
please people that's all i do
the first thing i really have to ask
about this one is what was your first
sort of i would say exposure to this
story like and coming back to it and
then what was it like sort of diving
into it from this new sort of
perspective
i didn't have very much experience with
it when it came out it's like it is not
it didn't even i didn't register i was
too young i don't remember it but what i
do remember which is maybe even more
messed up is that in my mind there it
was like this like tape was always just
like vaguely associated with pam
anderson as if she had something to do
with it as if it was a choice
or a part of
she crea she wanted this to be a part of
her narrative
um yeah so that's kind of and and and to
to learn what was really going on when i
started working on this show
was uh
really infuriating very humbling
again like how many
sort of
how much like cultural mythology that we
just kind of take for granted and um
certainly the dialogue around this whole
situation needs to be updated so i look
forward like so many things do you know
and it seems like right on time as we're
updating so many
systems or at least the the conversation
is changing the conversation around this
can
shift i think they're gonna be a lot of
justice for pam type trends after folks
get to see this series yeah i mean
wouldn't that be amazing i i think it's
in the in the sort of offing but then
your character erica it's it's
interesting like she's a different
player in this one and what was
i think people can look at her character
and maybe think they know who she is and
how she plays but what did what was
surprising to you about her as a
character and maybe how you tried to not
judge her in this sort of story
i mean i thought she was amazing and i
thought she was so vital to this
story also
she she's she's in charge of her choices
that's what i love about erica i mean
take it or leave it it doesn't really
matter like what her choices are but
she's in charge of them and she's happy
with them
which i love i
appreciate that in her and yeah and she
also is a sex worker
and so for her and she has complete
agency over whatever the hell she's
doing and i feel like that is a
counterpoint to how pam is being so
wildly exploited
is necessary in the show if we didn't
have a woman who was saying no this is
what
what you're d that's not porn that's
what you did to her is a violent crime
that it's a violent time that this is
out in the world without consent
what i do is there's consent it's not a
violent crime but do not call it porn
it's not it's it's a it's criminal like
if you you couldn't
you need erica to have that perspective
in the show i just have to give you to
talk just real quick about seth rogen
because you spend a lot of your time
with him and so just talking about him
in this in this role because i think for
some people they're going to see it as a
different look for him
i hope they do i mean he's magnificent i
think he's so
vulnerable and
and and like
and smart and
just like he's a
good actor he's so good and he was just
so generous and wonderful and i loved
working with him we had
i think we had a really really good time
fun
you